[Music]  a good friend of mine once said  the price of freedom is high  [Applause]  where do we start exclusively on disney  plus  so who would like to start  mr barnes why does sam aggravate you  15 seconds to drop so what's our plan  great  superheroes cannot be allowed  to exist  i have no intention to leave my work  unfinished  the wall's upside down right now  where do we start  oh yeah what is it is you ready  here we go again huh  hello girl kick your ass  [Music]  see that wasn't so hard are you ready  is you ready ready okay what are you  doing ready ready are you having a  staring contest  are you ready just  blank sweet jesus i mean how old  are you  [Music]  you